JJ BEHRENS: Are we ready?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Hey, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Come again.
Let's get started.
OK, welcome to the next
installment of Hangouts on Air
for YouTube APIs.
I'm JJ Behrens.
We have Jarek Wilkiewicz.
Jarek is a mild-mannered
developer relations guy by
day, hardcore Android
hacker by night.
And then there's Jeffrey
Posnick.
Can you wave, Jeffrey?
What can I say about Jeffrey?
Can I say that he's an eccentric
billionaire taking
gymnastics lessons who keeps
vowing to rid the
world of all evil?
Probably not.
I mean, that's Sergey Brin.
But I will say that when I see
him and Sergey Brin hanging
out together, they refer
to each other
as Batman and Robin.
And we also have Neal
Norwitz with us.
Neal Norwitz.
Man, I had to tackle, like,
three bodyguards to get this
guy out of the middle
of the Plex.
So senior software engineer.
He used to work on search, and
now he works on YouTube.
And then we have a guest today,
Adrian Holovaty, who is
famous on the Django project.
Pretty awesome.
Adrian, what do you have
to say for us today?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Hey, I'm just
hacking on a YouTube API for a
little side project.
So I just wanted to ask
a couple of questions
and see what's up.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sweet.
Cool.
Hey JJ, I heard you were hiding
in the Googleplex all
day yesterday.
What were you up to?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, man,
that was rough.
So I had to video two 45-minute
long tutorials, and
it actually took eight
and a half hours.
I've never done so many
takes in my life.
I mean, I thought I was going
to grow up to be a software
engineer, and instead I grew
up to be an actor.
But I'm super psyched.
We're going to release these
at Google AdWords slightly
before Google I/O, and
I think they're going
to be pretty awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool,
well, what are
they going to be about?
JJ BEHRENS: The first one is
YouTube For Your Business, and
then the second one is Using
Ruby on Rails and YouTube APIs
For Education.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, cool.
JJ BEHRENS: Since I'm surrounded
by Python, guys,
that's going to be a little of a
worry, having admitted that.
But it ought to be pretty
awesome, right?
So let me ask you a few
questions, since I've got Neal
for, like, 10 minutes before
he gets called back into
active duty.
I want to ask you a few
questions about software
development at Google and
YouTube since you've been here
for a while.
And I know that people love to
talk about these kind of
things, so tell me about the
programming languages that
Google uses.
NEAL NORWITZ: So Google has
primarily four main
programming languages that
are used very prevalently
throughout Google.
Those languages are C++, Java,
Python, and JavaScript.
All four of them are used for
fairly different purposes,
although there, of course,
is some overlap.
Many servers are implemented
in C++ and Java.
For YouTube, it's a little bit
of an exception, where the
primary language is Python for
most of the development.
Python is used throughout Google
for many scripting
environments, as far as things
used in production.
When we have tools that we want
to write, very often we
script them.
And of course, JavaScript is
used primarily on the client.
JJ BEHRENS: Great Can you tell
me a little bit about your
development environment?
I assume everyone uses
Eclipse, right?
NEAL NORWITZ: There are some
people that use Eclipse.
There's more people that
don't use Eclipse.
Like all the religious wars,
Google is good at them as
well, and for the editors, there
is everything from VI to
eMax, to Eclipse, to IntelliJ.
And to some extent, it depends a
little bit on the languages.
Java certainly uses IBEs
considerably more than many of
the old C and C++ hackers, as
well as Python, and so forth.
JJ BEHRENS: Sweet.
Great.
So I heard that Jeff, the
famous, infamous Jeff that
everyone always talks about,
still codes using just a
magnetized needle and a hard
drive, is that true?
NEAL NORWITZ: I think
now he's moved up.
He starts using Cat to just
append to the files, and then
that way he can keep adding more
new code that works just
perfectly, flawlessly
the first time.
JJ BEHRENS: Appended-only
editing, I mean, jeez, I wish
I would've taken that
class at school.
So tell me about a
day in your life.
What happens when you wake up?
What's it like to
live at Google?
NEAL NORWITZ: So mostly I
don't live at Google.
JJ BEHRENS: Sweet, I'm
glad to hear that.
NEAL NORWITZ: I recently bought
a house about seven
months ago and live
in the mountains.
But we spend a little bit of
time at Google, so I'm here
for about eight hours
a day now.
Sometimes a little bit less,
sometimes a little bit more,
depending upon what's
going on.
I get in now a little bit
earlier in the morning than
many people, which gives me a
really good chance to catch up
on email from the night before
and actually get some coding
done before everybody
gets in and the
email onslaught occurs.
And since I switched to YouTube,
I've actually been
doing a little bit more coding
than I was doing prior when I
was working the search.
JJ BEHRENS: Sweet.
And so throughout the course of
the day, obviously you have
to deal with email.
What other parts--
you get a little bit
of coding in.
How's that work?
NEAL NORWITZ: I'm very interrupt
driven, and so for
me I love being interrupted, and
email I can use to service
those interrupts.
If I have any downtime,
I can read email.
There's always lots of
threads going on.
There are code reviews
going on.
Code reviews are very common
throughout Google.
They're a required
part of our job.
So what I may intermix reading
some email with doing code
reviews, intermix it with
doing some coding.
I do have a few meetings here
and there, less than one a
day, though, at this point.
And so sometimes, then, I have
to run to a meeting, or maybe
grabbing lunch with a friend,
which is another meeting.
Or tomorrow it's breakfast
with a friend.
Today was breakfast with
somebody different.
So there's always something
going on.
Since Google is very
distributed, sometimes we have
VC meetings.
My meeting this morning was
through VC, similar to this.
But lots of other times, they're
face to face or a
combination of face
to face and VC.
JJ BEHRENS: Jarek, he says he
goes to one meeting a day.
How many meetings do you have
to go to on average?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Once per day,
I get to sit down and do
some coding.
JJ BEHRENS: That just goes to
prove that what I've been
saying all along is that
developer relations guys read
email and go to meetings
so that real
engineers don't have to.
NEAL NORWITZ: Sounds
good to me.
JJ BEHRENS: Google's really big
on data, and I know that
we do a lot of things
with data analysis.
Can you tell me how that
fits in with YouTube?
NEAL NORWITZ: Certainly.
YouTube is a part of Google and
similar in many respects.
And data collection
is no different.
We do like to be very focused
on the users, and so what we
do is we don't always know
what's going to work well for
users and what isn't.
So we run many different
experiments.
At any given time across many
different products--
most of the products,
in fact--
we are running many experiments
that will be
making sometimes very small
changes and other times very
large changes.
These changes can be visible to
you or, in the case of the
one I'm working on now, is a
pure infrastructure change,
which has very little visible
component to it.
We may be doing these
experiments to test stability,
we may be doing them to see what
colors work better for
users, when users can operate
faster, when they have less
mistakes, and so forth.
So by collecting the data based
on all the different
user interactions, we can tune
the UI to do a much better job
and service users better.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
Pretty awesome.
Now before I came to Google, I
was really, really big into
code quality.
Well, I'm still into code
quality, but that's one of the
reasons I came to Google.
I'd heard so much about the
steps that Google used to
maintain high code quality.
Can you tell me about those?
NEAL NORWITZ: So I already
mentioned code review.
That's one of the primary
techniques that we use at
Google to improve code quality,
as well as to prevent
any sorts of problems
down the road.
It also helps communicate
intent to different
developers.
Some people do pair programming,
which can be very
beneficial as far as
communication goes.
Many teams do not use that, but
code reviews are a way of
getting closer to that and
helping spread the knowledge
as far as across
the code base.
Since we have a very large code
base, it's very important
to know many different
portions of it.
In addition to code reviews,
we also have a very strong
testing culture throughout
Google.
It's something that early in my
Google career I helped to
improve and make
much stronger.
It's interesting, the different
perspectives that
people have as far as testing
and how it's evolved over
time, where we've attempted to
drive more people to do unit
testing so that we can, again,
find problems sooner and
prevent the problems from
ever getting to users.
JJ BEHRENS: So one thing that
I've heard from a lot of
people who visit Google is
that even going to the
bathroom at Google makes you
want to be a better tester.
Can you tell me about this?
NEAL NORWITZ: So this
is something
that there is a team.
There is grouplets at Google.
These are groups of volunteers
that are
interested in any one task.
In this case, the testing
grouplet had just reformed
when I joined Google nearly
seven years ago, and we wanted
to improve testing at Google.
We were trying to figure
out ways that we
could improve testing.
Google has a fairly collegiate
environment, and so there were
already many posters on the
walls, but the bathrooms were
pretty bare.
We figured, where can we get a
community of people that have
no other choice but to read
the material we wanted to
present to them.
And so we started putting
them up in the bathroom.
It was a little bit of a joke,
and again, I was talking about
experimentation earlier.
This was one experiment, and
it happened to be one
experiment that was
very successful.
Nearly 300 episodes have been
run since we started it many
years ago, and across a
wide range of topics.
And in this way, it's become
part of the Google culture,
and it's helped educate
people.
And we try to entertain people
at the same time, because we
don't want to make it too dry
and boring when you're already
doing a pretty mundane task.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty awesome.
That just goes to show you that
the best way to learn how
to not core dump is
to take a dump.
NEAL NORWITZ: Exactly.
JJ BEHRENS: So can you tell me
about how designs get done at
Google, in terms of how do we
make sure that one rogue
engineer doesn't end
up doing something
that's not really scalable?
NEAL NORWITZ: So one of the
things that we do, especially
on larger projects, is
run design reviews.
So Google is fairly light on
many points of documentation,
but design docs are pretty
common throughout Google.
And when bigger changes are
made, very often design docs
are requested.
Out on my prior team, one of my
tasks was to run the whole
design review process, where
as teams wanted to add new
features, they would have to
create a design doc that would
explain what they
wanted to do.
And we would have a meeting
where many different people
across the organization would
come together and figure out,
is this going to work on
the production side?
Is this going to work from
the coding side?
In the case of our team, we
maintained the infrastructure,
but others were adding features
to the infrastructure
that we were maintaining.
So we had to make sure that the
features were added in a
maintainable fashion.
And so design reviews were,
again, a way that we could
find problems faster and before
we ever got to the code
review phase, or certainly
before we got to production.
That's not to say that mistakes
haven't been made.
There have definitely been some
products that have been
released where they've pretty
much fallen over.
Many users have experienced
that, but we strive to do
better each time and learn
from our mistakes.
So one of the other things we
do, in addition to design
reviews, the other side of the
culture that's very strong at
Google is having postmortems.
So whenever there's a failure,
whenever there's a large
outage, we ask for
a postmortem.
And this, again, spans many
different products and many
different projects, such
that we can try to
learn from our mistakes.
There are action items
that come out.
We attempt to address the action
items so that we can
prevent these same problems from
occurring in the future.
JJ BEHRENS: So I think it's
pretty well known that Google
uses Linux.
Now do you use Linux in your
development environment?
NEAL NORWITZ: I do.
On a day-to-day basis, my
desktop is Linux, and for me
it's very natural, since prior
to coming to Google I've used
Linux for, I don't know, 10-plus
years at that point.
So it was a great environment
for me to come here.
And most developers, virtually
all developers, unless they're
specifically developing for
Windows or for Mac or
something like that, if
they're doing a client
application--
like Chrome would
be one example--
almost all developers are
using Linux for their
day-to-day development.
JJ BEHRENS: Right on.
So since Google is a big user
of Linux, I know that Google
kind of contributes back
to open source.
Can you tell me about that?
NEAL NORWITZ: Sure.
Prior to coming to Google, I
actually was involved with
several open source projects,
Python being the most well
known one, for sure.
And once I got to Google, I
continued working on Python
for several years, actually
and was fairly well known
within the Python community.
These days, I might have
a much lower profile.
JJ BEHRENS: I still think
you're famous.
NEAL NORWITZ: But I
still work on many
different Python tasks.
Since I recently switched to
YouTube, one of the open
source projects that I've been
working on is Spitfire.
And so since we use Spitfire
within YouTube, one of my jobs
has been to improve
the efficiency of
Spitfire for YouTube.
And so I've been submitting
little performance
fixes here and there.
One of the other tools that I
have developed in the past as
part of Google, I did a lot of
C++ work, and so I wanted to
do some lightweight
analysis of C++.
This is prior to client being
a much better development
environment for C++ and
having a much richer
set of tools available.
And so I just wanted to do quick
and dirty scripts, and
so I wrote a C++ parser, or
approximate parser in Python
and released this part as open
source, which is very common
throughout Google.
As we have scripts that are not
the core search part of
Google, we try to get as much as
possible out into the open
source community, if nothing
else, to make it available so
that others can learn.
And if we get contributions,
that's great, and certainly
helping others so that they can
innovate faster, so that
they can develop more tools
without having to develop all
the basic building blocks.
JJ BEHRENS: So you said that
you're actually parsing C++
with Python?
I thought only PEARL and
Bjarne Stroupstrup were
capable of such a feat.
NEAL NORWITZ: It's, like I said,
an approximate parser.
It doesn't do many different
constructs, but it did do a
significant part of Google's
code base at the time.
This was several years ago
now, which was many, many
lines of code.
And I ran it through the whole
Google code base, and it did
90-plus percent of Google code
base [INAUDIBLE] parsed.
And it just gave me an AST--
an Abstract Syntax Tree--
representation of the code
so that I could do some
transformations.
One of the things that we used
for it was to find cases where
we had a base class that had
virtual methods but no virtual
destructor.
If you don't know C++, this can
be very bad because the
destructor can then not
be called in certain
circumstances, and you may leak
memory, or you may do
other bad things like code
locks, in which case your
entire program will deadlock,
and that's
not such a good thing.
JJ BEHRENS: Deadlock?
I've never seen that.
NEAL NORWITZ: No, not
in Google code.
JJ BEHRENS: So you mentioned
Spitfire, and I know that
that's not as well known as
some other projects in the
Python world.
Can you tell me what it is?
NEAL NORWITZ: Sure.
It's a template engine.
So it was based off of Cheetah,
which is probably a
little bit better known.
But there were certain things
that YouTube, back in the day,
needed out of the templating
engine, and so they wrote
their own and then open sourced
it, that being Spitfire.
So Django is much more
commonly used today.
Many more people know that.
And it's used for certain
circumstances.
But YouTube already has a very
large code base written in
Spitfire, and so in order for
us to change out of Spitfire
to something else, we would need
a very large benefit that
we would gain as well.
And so far we haven't been able
to determine that we can
do that much better with another
templating language,
and so we use that for pretty
much all of our HTML
generation.
So we have the Python code that
fills dictionaries, and
then those dictionaries
are rendered
into HTML by Spitfire.
JJ BEHRENS: That's funny, I
haven't heard people talk
about Cheetah very much lately,
but I remember talking
to the author, recently,
of Python.
So a lot of people have heard
of this 20% thing at Google,
and a lot of people ask me,
is this fact or fiction?
NEAL NORWITZ: For
sure, it's fact.
It is very well encouraged
throughout
Google to take 20% time.
Unfortunately, many people do
not, and at times I've been
guilty of this as well.
The good thing is that you can
bank it, and so it's not
actually tracked.
If you wanted to do 100% time
for two weeks, and not do any
20% time for a year on a 20%
project, that's just fine.
If you want to do one
day a week, that
would also work well.
As I said, many people don't
use it, which is a bit
unfortunate and not really
what the company wants.
But it's a reality based on how
happy so many developers
here at Google are and that we
are very much entertained by
our day job and enthusiastic
about our day job that
sometimes it's hard to take a
step back and try to work on
something else.
And some people just don't have
any particular ideas.
I mentioned grouplets earlier.
Grouplets are another way of
contributing to 20% time that
many people throughout
Google actually use.
And so in order to make the
whole of Google a better
place, they invest their time
as a volunteer working on
something that is not a formal
part of Google in any way.
The grouplets overall are, but
any individual grouplet may or
may not be really formalized.
And they just try to get
done the tasks that
they view as important.
JJ BEHRENS: Great so you
mentioned earlier you did some
stuff at Google Open Source.
Was that a 20% project
at the time?
NEAL NORWITZ: It was.
So the project I was working on
was C++, and so I did a lot
of it in my own time, and then I
also did a fair amount of it
on Google time as well.
And that would be all 20% time
that I worked on it.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So I know that it's a little
bit strange when engineers
first come to Google, and in
the Python world, a lot of
people comment that Google is
a black hole for Python
programmers, because if you're
on event horizon close enough
to Google to get sucked in,
you'll get sucked in, and
people might not hear from
you for a little while.
Why is that?
NEAL NORWITZ: The various
different reasons, like again,
I mentioned earlier that people
are very enthusiastic
when they come to Google.
And that enthusiasm
doesn't even wane
after many years sometimes.
I've been here for nearly seven
years, and when I start
getting bored of a project,
I switch projects.
I've been on three primary
projects here at Google.
My most previous project I had
been offered up four and a
half years.
Since that was a C++ project,
I didn't do that
much work in Python.
However, now that I've gone to
YouTube, and I'm starting to
do a lot more Python work again,
I'm getting more back
into the Python community and
contributing back to Spitfire
and doing some of the
things that I had
done many years ago.
And so many people, if they've
been at Google long enough,
will go through various cycles
where they are doing more open
source, and then less open
source, and then they can go
back to doing more
open source.
JJ BEHRENS: Cool.
So I guess the rumors that
engineers have to spend, like,
50% of their time avoiding
getting hit by self-driving
cars is probably not true?
NEAL NORWITZ: Probably not,
although I don't know too many
people that work there, so
I should hold judgment.
JJ BEHRENS: OK.
Neal, I really appreciate
your coming in today.
Thanks a lot.
NEAL NORWITZ: Thank you.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks.
NEAL NORWITZ: Good day.
JJ BEHRENS: So now let's do some
Q&A. And Adrian is here,
another famous Python guy.
What have you got
for us, Adrian?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK, turning
on my mic here.
So it's the right time now
to ask, just like, really
technical questions
about the API?
JJ BEHRENS: Jeffrey's already
sending an email with an
answer key, you know, for the
sake of the audience.
Why don't you ask your question,
and then he'll say
it verbally.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Oh, sure.
So I have, actually,
a couple questions.
The first is, what's the best
way to get more granularity in
the YouTube player
API in JavaScript
for the current position?
So I think the current, it's
only every, maybe, 200
milliseconds?
JJ BEHRENS: Jeffrey, can
I answer this one?
Because I'm so excited
I actually know the
answer to this one.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I am so
happy for you, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks.
So of course we have an iframe
player that uses either Flash
or HTML5, and it turns out with
Flash, there are these
things called key frames that
are in the stream, and so you
really can't see to anything
more finer
grained than a key frame.
So it's actually not so much of
a YouTube thing as it is a
core thing about Flash.
And so this comes up a lot
with Flash developers.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK, so if I
were to switch to the HTML5
player, would there be a way
of getting around it?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so as a
YouTube API user, you
generally don't pick which
player you want to use,
because, of course, different
players are used in different
environments.
And so there are some
environments, like iOS, that
don't even support Flash.
Then there are some environments
that don't
support HTML5, and so basically
you have to coach
the HTML5 to the iframe API, and
you kind of have to deal
with the limitations.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: One thing you
might consider, though, is
test it out with
HTML5 enabled.
So if you go youtube.com/html5
you can enroll.
It's a cookie that gets saved in
your browser, so it's just
for a single user.
We don't really have a
documented way to switch and
force the iframe player
to play HTML5.
The idea being that we try to
make it transparent for
developers, and eventually the
functionality should really be
equivalent.
It is still not.
But then, yeah, there's cases
where HTML5 might actually do
a little better already, so I'll
be very interested to see
if HTML5 actually improves that
for you, because we could
give to our team and see
if there's anything
that they could do.
And maybe for certain cases,
we should allow forcing the
HTML5 playback with certain
types of applications.
We purposely have not exposed
it so that the complexity is
hidden from the application
developer.
But I did also hear some
evidence that when it comes to
the resolution, it's
actually a little
better with HTML5 playback.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Sorry, Adrian,
I just wanted to see
if you could clarify a little
bit what you're doing with
these time stamps.
Are you seeking to a specific
time stamp, or are you just
trying to get the current time
of the playing video, and you
want a higher resolution
of the current time?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY:
Good question.
I'm actually doing both, but
more of the second one, where
I have like a timeline view of
the video, and I just want to
have a play head that's really
nice and smooth, instead of
really choppy, because the
resolution's fine.
So I'm getting around it by
using set timeout between
calls to get current time, so
that sort of just fakes it,
but I'm just wondering if
there was a better way.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I could answer
that a little bit more.
I recently went to an HTML5
conference and went to a talk
on animation.
And one of the things that a
YouTube developer there was
talking about was there's a new
API called Get Animation
Frame, and this works out a
little bit better than set
timeout for various reasons.
But if you have an idea of the
key frame, then you could kind
of fake it a little bit in order
to get the smoother flow
of the timeline.
So I haven't tried that exactly,
but that's probably
what I would go try to do.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK, Get
Animation Frame?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, so you use
Get Animation Frame as the
backbone for your animations,
and then maybe you measure how
long the key frame interval is,
and then thereafter you
set up a smooth animation
using even CSS.
You don't even need to
do it in JavaScript.
You could to do it in
CSS to some degree.
So you could have the
progression animating and
update the animation
in response to
changes in the play head.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Got it.
Cool.
JJ BEHRENS: Just because you're
not getting enough call
backs doesn't mean that you
can't be animating that time.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Sure.
OK, cool.
I'll definitely check
that out.
And then can I ask
another one?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Please do.
JJ BEHRENS: Well, you there's
a large crowd behind you.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: I've been
posting videos to YouTube
since 2007 or something
like that.
And I've got around 24,000
subscribers, and I would like
to be able to reach the
subscribers who have been with
me for a long period of time,
for four years or whatever.
And I don't think that there's
currently a way in the data
API to get at the day
they subscribed.
Can you think of a way that I
can get at the early people,
to sort of give them maybe a
special thanks for being with
me for a long time, or
something like that?
JJ BEHRENS: Jeffrey,
what do you say?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, so it's
not really symmetrical, the
type of information that we
expose regarding subscriptions
in the API.
You're kind of making the
assumption that there's some
way to get the list of people
that are subscribed to you and
asking about how to find the
date which that subscription
took place.
But the first part of that
actually is impossible.
You can't get a list of
everybody who subscribed to
you using the data API.
What you can do is get a list
of everybody that you are
subscribed to, so if you
get a list of your own
subscriptions, but not
the people that are
subscribed to you.
So there's a fundamental
problems with exposing the
time stamps of people's start
of their subscription.
That information just isn't
available via the data API to
begin with.
JJ BEHRENS: You know, I have
kind of a crazy idea.
If you've been a Gmail user
this whole time, Gmail
actually has an API as well,
and you might be able to
search for the email that you
get when someone subscribes to
you, and do it that way.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: That's clever,
but I turned off those
emails many years ago.
JJ BEHRENS: I don't know why.
I mean, what's wrong
with 24,000 emails?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I think the
only other option is, you can
engage with your users on your
channel, and that's what,
typically, people do.
So uploading your video is one
thing, but now there is
basically a wall of sorts where
you can post updates,
and so forth.
So if you, for example, want
to interact with them, then
you could post some notices
there, and if they subscribe
to you, they will get that
in their stream.
So that's typically what people
do for engagement with
their audiences.
They basically use the YouTube
Channel page, and then
depending on how you configure
your channel, you can actually
configure it in a way that
features the activity from you
a little more prominently.
And so there's engagement around
a single video, but
there's also engagement
on the channel.
So I think using that might be a
good way to achieve whatever
it is that you wanted
to send them.
Through email, you could try to
do this on the channel and
see if that works for you,
because it typically is what
YouTube stars, such
as yourself, do.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK.
JJ BEHRENS: So Adrian, I'm
not subscribed to you.
But I do remember you
play guitar, right?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: So I've seen one
of your videos, and your
guitar playing's pretty
dang amazing.
I remember when I first watched
it, I was like, holy
crap, he's a damn good Python
programmer, as well as an
amazing guitarist. I mean,
that's just not fair.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Thanks, man.
I wish I could do it full time,
but it's hard to make a
living as a musician,
you know?
JJ BEHRENS: You want to mention
where the name Django
came from, then?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Oh,
yeah, it's named
after Django Reinhardt.
He was a jazz guitarist
in the '30s and '40s.
That's basically it.
JJ BEHRENS: Pretty cool.
Do you have more questions?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: This is very,
very low level, but I guess
while I have you--
on the iPad, I've noticed that
when you press Play, in the
JavaScript API, it actually
falsely reports that it's
playing for three
or four seconds.
And then after, like, three or
four seconds, then the get
current position goes back to
zero, and then it's correct.
Does this make sense?
Is this a known thing?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You're using
the iframe player, right?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
Interesting.
I haven't seen that before,
but that would
probably be a bug.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, it
unfortunately might be a bug
in the way the HTML5
video element is
implemented on iOS web kit.
Just in general, the iframe API
tends to be a fairly light
layer over the native events
exposed by the browser's HTML5
video implementation.
So you do occasionally see
differences in what might be
recorded in terms of
the player states.
And it's probably for the best
that the iframe API tries to
stay out of the way and just
report what's going on in the
browser, rather than imposing
its own logic and having
special cases hard coded, like
if this is iOS, then I should
wait a few seconds before
I report playback, or
something like that.
But if I had to take a guess,
I would say that that's
probably what the
root cause is.
But we could talk to the player
engineering team and
ask them to confirm that and
look into it a little bit
more, and maybe even file
required bugs against web kit
folks if needed.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK.
I'm happy to send a little
example thing if that would be
useful
JEFFREY POSNICK: That
would be fantastic.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: OK.
JEFFREY POSNICK: I know that we
take iframe API bugs super,
super seriously.
We want to get those completely
squashed, and that
API, we want it to be
completely solid.
And an example will really
help the team, so we'd be
really grateful for that.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Sure.
Sounds good.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Feel free to
do that via our Google group
that we have set up for YouTube
data and player API
questions and bug reports
and things like that.
It is being slightly neglected
right now.
All of us are super busy getting
ready for Google I/O.
So apologies to anybody who is
watching this video and has
recently posted a question to
our group that we haven't had
a chance to get to you
yet, but these
things will not be ignored.
It's just a slight delay in
getting back to folks.
JJ BEHRENS: So by slightly
neglected, do you mean that
your average response time has
fallen from a mere 45 seconds
to like, 57 seconds?
JEFFREY POSNICK: It might be
slightly more dramatic than
that, but we want to make sure
that everybody knows that
they're being heard, even if
they're not hearing back a
response right away.
JJ BEHRENS: Adrian,
is that it?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah,
that's it for me.
Thanks so much.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How was
the sandwitch, Adrian?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: I'm sorry?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How
was the sandwich?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Oh,
it was good.
Sorry, I put myself on mute,
went on visual mute, so you
wouldn't see me, you know--
JJ BEHRENS: So are you
still in Chicago now?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: Right on.
How's the weather?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Beautiful
today.
Yeah.
Very nice.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
Jeffrey, what was the best
question you got asked on the
Google group recently?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Best question
is a little tough, but I can
say that I have been helping
some very patient developers
recently in the Google
group [INAUDIBLE]
bear with a few bugs that's been
ongoing with our player
APIs in particular.
So I'll briefly talk
about that.
So we have been having some
issues related to the default
playback quality that's
being used for--
I think in particular, it's
been the Chromeless
ActionScript 3 player.
And some folks have rightfully
been upset because we ended up
defaulting to basically
a 240p, which is our
lowest-quality version of the
video, even if the player is
large enough for
a 720p version.
This has purely just been due to
some issues on our end that
were introduced with some recent
changes to the quality
selection code, and I think
everything should be fully
ironed out by the end of the
day today when we do our
weekly push of the YouTube
players and the associated
code for that.
So thanks for everybody's
patience regarding that.
JJ BEHRENS: And Jarek, I know
you've been working pretty
hard on setting up sandbox
partners for Google I/O. And I
don't want to get the whole
list just yet, but can you
give us any teasers of what
we're going to see?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So we'll be
announcing the list shortly on
our Google I/O site.
I can tell you that we'll have
12 partners this year, so
quite a few application
developers that use YouTube
API for a very wide
range of products.
So if you're out there building
an awesome app, and
one day you feel like you need
more exposure, maybe next year
you could join us at
Google I/O as well.
This is of the things that we
are trying to do for our
application developers, to
help them get noticed.
I know it's a huge press event
for us as well, so we expect
good coverage.
And yeah, we've been busy
getting it all together.
The list should be coming out
soon, so if you're coming to
I/O, I hope you'll visit
our sandbox.
We'll have some very
exciting demos.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow, that's
pretty awesome.
I heard something about spying
on people, and I heard weird
Scottish accents with
you on the phone.
I just can't understand
what's going on.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We will have
a nice international
representation.
Since I speak with an accent,
I'm trying to kind of foster
that within my immediate
neighborhood.
So we have more weird accents
in the developer sandbox.
But I think about 33% of
participants will be from
outside of the United States.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow,
I'd have to say
that's pure dead brilliant.
So I think we're out
of time today.
Thank you, Adrian.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: I do have
one more question.
Is it too late?
JEFFREY POSNICK: No, perfect.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: So I'm working
on looping sections of
videos with that same iframe
API, and I've noticed that
even if the loop
is very small--
so, like, one second's
worth of stuff--
every time it goes back to the
start, it requests the
underlying video data again.
And I'm wondering
if there is--
that seems very inefficient.
So is there a way to just have
it cache that somehow or
somehow clue it in that it's
already seen that portion of
the video, and it shouldn't
have to download again?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Which player?
Is it Flash, or HTML5 player?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: I would assume
it's the Flash one,
because I'm using that iframe
API, and it picks it
automatically, right?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Just
on the desktop?
ADRIAN HOLOVATY: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
No, I don't think we cache
that right now.
I think in theory with Flash,
there are some possibilities,
but we don't do that
right now.
I mean, this is obviously
good feedback.
I'm going to bring this up with
the players team, because
frankly I think it's a little
overkill to do that.
We only now are getting into
allowing people to script the
playback with the API and player
parameters, so I this
is probably going to become
more and more of an issue
going forward as people
use the API.
JJ BEHRENS: Think it's a good
feature request. OK Thank you,
Adrian, so much for joining
our hangout.
You made it a lot more fun
having some live questions.
And for all the people watching
the live streaming,
thanks for joining, and we'll
be posting this probably on
Google Developers site.
So thanks a lot, guys.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks, guys.
Bye, bye.
ADRIAN HOLOVATY:
Bye, everybody.